après la mise en liquidation judiciaire
de la norml hier les salariés précisé
qu'il ne voulait pas renoncer
aujourd'hui serge dupouy et christiane
pied se sont rendus à la ciotat et ont
pris le pouls de la cité comment la
ciotat vite elle humainement ce drame
économique
réponse dans ce reportage ce matin à la
ciotat la population était triste la
plupart des commerçants également vides
étaient les terrasses des restaurants et
mélancolique les keufs qui est exemple
celui ci qui malgré son sourire a vu
considérablement baissé sa clientèle
depuis quelques années avant c'était
mbark vous faut pas rater
j'avais même de voile de surtout pas
saisir aussi puisqu'on attendait la
sortie
la sortie de 12h30 dit abdou 0,7 et play
est aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui je vois
d'abord vous avez aperçu voiliers a
presque plus faire ça là puisque c'est
un coin ici sa foi ici dire ça fait
partie des chaînes qui est et ça ça va
mal au coeur de revenir par la voyait
autres secteurs l'immobilier qui connaît
ici une régression depuis 1982 en outre
peut-on penser que des reventes de bien
des employés de la norme aide se réalise
nous ne soutenons pas à part le
changement cliquer directement la sur
terre je peux pas dire que les gens sont
de nouveau à bombay parce que vous savez
plus où moins les gens quand ils font
des offres
il ya des assurances chômage il ya des
assurances sur l'endroit
donc ces assurances je pense
automatiquement d'autres jouent à
l'heure actuelle sur le plan médical des
problèmes de compensation se pose un
syndrome dépressif touche une partie de
la population tandis que les anciens du
chantier ceux de plus de 40 ans
connaissent eu des problèmes cardiaques
et digestion pour les jeunes le problème
est différent il ya aussi un homme n'est
pas si important et c'est surtout parce
que l'avenir leur paraît complètement
masqué et qu'il n'aura pas eu tout ce
qu'il pourrait faire
il reste à la ciotat en fait ils ne
savent pas où aller ailleurs retrouvé de
l'emploi
vu la situation actuelle et 7
vision très noire de leur avenir et une
introduction encore plus facile que dans
un endroit vers la toxicomanie sous le
choc donc la ville industrielle de la
ciotat néanmoins aujourd'hui la majorité
de la population parce qu'il faut
repartir sur de nouvelles bases
pourquoi pas le tourisme chantiers
navals de la ciotat longtemps ce matin à
la ciotat la population était triste la
plupart des commerçants également vides
étaient les terrasses des restaurants et
mélancolique les cafetiers exemple celui
ci qui malgré son sourire a vu
considérablement baissé sa clientèle
depuis quelques années avant c'était
mbark boussoufa part à vrai dire et paix
devant ne surtout pas saisir aussi
puisqu'on attendait la sortie
la sortie de 12h30 10 à 12 07 et plec
est aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui je veux
d'abord vous avez aperçu voiliers a
presque plus personne puisque c'est un
coin ici ça soit ici 10 ans a fait
partie des chaînes qui est et ça c'est
le gag mal au coeur de revenir par la
voyait autres secteurs l'immobilier qui
connaît ici une régression depuis 1982
en outre peut-on penser que des reventes
de bien des employés de la norme aide se
réalise ou absolument pas
la parution de citer directement la
source des jeux peut pas dire que les
gens sont de me voir et me disent ah bon
parce que vous savez plus où moins les
gens quand ils font des emprunts il ya
des assurances chômage y ait des
assurances sur l'emploi dans ca sur un
jeu passe automatiquement donc jouent
alors actuelle sur le plan médical des
problèmes de compensation se pose un
syndrome dépressif touche une partie de
la population tandis que les anciens du
chantier ceux de plus de 40 ans
connaissent eu des problèmes cardiaques
et digestif pour les jeunes le problème
est différent il ya aussi un hammam
n'est pas si l'important était surtout
pas ce que l'avenir leur paraît
complètement masqué mais qui n'aura pas
eu tout ce qu'il pourrait faire
il reste à la surface qu'en fait ils ne
savent pas où aller ailleurs retrouvé de
l'emploi
vu la situation actuelle et cette vision
très noire de leur avenir
et puis une introduction encore plus
facile que dans les endroits vers la
toxicomanie sous le choc donc la ville
industrielle de la ciotat néanmoins
aujourd'hui la majorité de la population
parce qu'il faut repartir sur de
nouvelles bases
pourquoi pas le tourisme